COLBY HYLAND:
Dance, to me, really
is kind of the ultimate
expression of myself.
I think from when I
started at eight years old
until now, dance has
been one of the most
constant aspects of my life.
I'm Colby Hyland.
I'm a junior here at Princeton.
I'm majoring in
molecular biology,
and I'm pursuing a
certificate in dance.
I try to dance almost every day,
whether that's in the Princeton
program in dance,
whether that's kind
of just going to a
studio with my friends
and hang out, or actually
working with choreographers
that Princeton brings
to campus and getting
real works set on us.
ORI FLOMIN: Colby is a
teacher's dream, really.
He's hardworking, he
takes corrections well,
he's always prompt and
on time and responsible.
One thing I told
all the students,
I said, you need to be
responsible with your role,
so when I come
back to the studio,
you remember what
we did last week.
It's not like we start
everything from beginning,
so we can push forward.
And I want to see,
when I'm coming,
I want to see you've practiced.
I want to see that
you know the material.
And he really took all that
in and has been working hard
and, yeah, he looks great.
COLBY HYLAND: With
molecular biology,
there is a lot with
patterning and signaling
and kind of how molecules
are all working together.
I think in that way,
there can be a lot related
to dance in terms
of cooperativity
and how bodies move in space.
So maybe there's
not a direct link
as so much like art
and molecular biology.
But I think the
fundamental concepts
of maybe movement and
patterns and things
like that could definitely
be explored with dance.
Something that I've really
loved about Princeton
is just that I can explore
so many different styles.
It seems like every semester
you're kind of challenged
with something
completely different.
I mean, even if it's
contemporary dance,
there's just such a
wide array of actually
what contemporary dance is.
How is my personality changing?
How are my
relationships changing?
How is everything
that I'm experiencing
in the world changing?
And to explore that
in this art form,
and to really find whether
it's emotional or mental or
physical, to really
explore that through dance,
throughout my lifetime,
has been really the best
expression of myself,
and has really shown me
and taught me so much that
I'm really thankful for.